newly released video appears to show a
Ukrainian Naval drone targeting a
Russian warship the Russian defense
Ministry said a drone attack had been
foiled at a naval base in the Black Sea
port of novotzisk another video later
showed a damaged warship being towed
away
and Russia also says the defense
minister has met senior Russian military
commanders in Donetsk in eastern Ukraine
Fierce fighting is taking place in the
region it's not clear when Sergei was in
the city of Lehman ilas visited combat
areas in June and that was following the
Mutiny by Wagner mercenaries in southern
Russia
served as the fifth president of Ukraine
from 2014 to 2019 and he's joining us
now from Kiev so thank you very much
indeed for being with us on Al Jazeera I
want to ask you about the the Drone
attacks the one that we've seen on the
ship and on the Russian ship but also
previous ones we've seen recently on
buildings in Moscow I know Ukraine has
made its situation there has not made
its situation regarding those
particularly clear but what do isolated
drone attacks on Russian trips and
individual Moscow buildings serve for
Ukraine
I cannot command the attack on the
individual Moscow building because we
don't have a confirmation from the
Ukrainian authorities but definitely I
have no doubt that the Russian warship
who attacked Ukraine is a legal War goal
a legal military goal for Ukrainian
armed forces and I'm proud that it is me
who was Supreme commander-in-chief of
Ukrainian Armed Forces create the Armed
Force of Ukraine based on the NATO
standard and we have an opportunity to
set to the defend Ukrainian territory
Ukrainian sovereignty Ukrainian
territorial integrity and given the
legal assessment this is the
self-defense Target
with regard to Ukraine's much documented
counter-offensive do you have confidence
that Ukraine's government is able to get
the support that it needs from NATO
members and other foreign governments
around the world particularly when it
comes to air security for example
because that seems to be a region where
our foreign governments are particularly
pushing back are you able to achieve
what you really want when it comes to
asking foreign governments for help
first of all I want to tell you that I
returned back from the battlefield from
the front line just a couple of hours
ago this morning and yesterday I was the
whole day together with our paratroopers
with our Marine Corps with our artillery
specialist and I want to deliver you
that Ukrainian troops has a very high
moral spirit and I have no doubt about
the perspective for the
counter-offensive operation of Ukrainian
Armed Forces this is point number one
point number two that we have during
this almost 18 months of the war of the
uh full size full-scale War because we
have a war since year 2014 and my
presidency when we defended the Ukraine
this long five years so now we have a
confirmation from our partners U.S Great
Britain European Union NATO would be
together with us until our victory
listen once again not until the end but
until our Victory and we have
significantly improved situation with
the uh ammunition we definitely count to
receive the air defense we definitely
count and now in August we will launch
the special training courses for
Ukrainian pilot for the F-16 and I just
want to deliver you information that
this is not a Hollywood movie and this
is not doing like that and for every
success of Ukrainian Army this is a
great efforts great sacrifice of
Ukrainian soldiers and we understand
what does it mean for the whole world we
stopping the aggressor we do not give
ability of Russia to attack freedom and
democracy in the whole world and I want
to appreciate to all of our partners in
the West in the south in the East
including our partners in the Arab world
on the Middle East for supporting our
efforts to peace because you cannot find
out any nation in the world who want a
peace more than we Ukrainian because
every single night we have a Russian
missile attack on the civilian object
Russian missile attack on the object of
the critical energy infrastructure and
this is just a demonstrating the new
evidence that Russia provide the war
like a terroristic States and the
Russian soldiers is a terrorist and the
Russian leader Putin is a war criminal
this is what we have the conclusion for
the last 18 months there is a piece in
it has been arranged by Saudi Arabia
Ukraine has said it's going to be there
along with Brazil India South Africa the
U.S upon is going to have a presence
there's an understanding that China is
going to be there as well the one
country of course that's not going to be
there is going to be Russia what do you
think you can achieve
first of all I want to thank Saudi
Arabia for the this important initiative
and I think that
I hope I keep my fingers crossed that
it's help us to create a
reliable framework for their
formalization of the peace negotiation
and the only one precondition for peace
negotiation is to restore the
sovereignty and territorial Integrity on
Ukrainian territory in the international
recognized border very clear all other
things all other aspects aspects
including the Global Security Regional
security
reparation compensation
lifting function all other things we
would be happy to do and the Victory how
to motivate Russia to do that first of
all we have one of the best diplomats in
the world who is extremely effective in
negotiation with Russia the name of this
Diplomat is armed forces of Ukraine and
the second point for the peace is the
sanction and if we cut the Russian cash
flow Russian export to limit the ability
to finance the war this is another
important things and the Saudi Arabia is
a key player for the oil Market has a
extremely efficient instrument in their
hands
third is that the we are not talking
only about the West we're talking about
the global South and the global
east with the Asia that they're also
involved in this Global crisis because
of the Russian aggression I am very much
Happy that the Saudi Arabia's original
leader has a success for inviting India
has a success for inviting Brazil and
now I don't have the confirmation of
this information but I hear now in your
TV show that China is also accept the
invitation and will participate in the
this consultation this is extremely
important I'm really hope keep fingers
crossed for as a results of this Summit
we will have a communique who
make
pressure on Russia to stop the war and
this is a absolutely evidence that this
is was not only about Ukraine it's not
only about Europe this is more about the
whole world because now for uh because
of the Russia blocking the Black Sea
port of Ukraine with Ukrainian grain can
you imagine
400 million people has a hunger in their
Nations and only now for the 15 percent
the price for the grain is a main food
is going up because of Russia and with
that situation that make a
worse the life of the least
developed Nation the poorest nation in
the world and the role of this Saudi
Arabia and the guest of your summit
would be definitely very much important
over the last uh two or three weeks
we've seen Russia increasing the amount
of Aid and support that it's giving to a
variety of countries around the world
not least of course African nations who
were represented at meetings with
President Putin just a couple of weeks
or so ago President Putin has been
promising increased Aid to them one can
understand the concerns that they
themselves has countries have How
concerned is Ukraine that this Aid and
support from Russia could change the
balance of support if you like or the
level of support that Ukraine is getting
in the conflict
I have two recommendations
recommendation number one
please
don't trust Putin
if Russia said that they increased their
support for their
African world
this is simply not true
Russia want to supply their grain
Supply their fertilizer at the increased
price for 15 percent and give some
couple of dozens a thousand tone as a
bribe to those leaders who come to
Russia
don't trust Putin you will pay a highest
price and put in as a KGB officer
definitely make a lie and second
position please don't be afraid of put
you when we are together when we are
cut the Russian expert when we stop
Russian ability to finance the war and
introduce the sanction this is the most
efficient instrument how to lowering the
prices for the food products in the
world and that would be the position how
to support the least developed world we
put in understand only one language
and this is not Russian or German
language this is the language of
strength and I definitely hope that the
meeting in area meeting in Saudi Arabia
will reach the results to speak with the
Putin with the language of strength and
this is the only language he understand
and this is the only language who can be
effective in the pressure on Russia to
stop the war to bring the peace to stop
blocking the global trade and to
facilitate the life of the poor people
in the whole world Petro poroshenko we
appreciate you being with us and Al
Jazeera so thank you very much indeed
for your time